[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting for the pods
moving in storage studio it's the ramsey
show where that is dumb cash is king and
the paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice we help people build wealth do
work that they actually love and create
real amazing relationships george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print podcast on ramsey networks is
my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
if you happen to be running around uh
new york city
for some reason or another and you're in
uh times square look up you'll see us
uh the fine folks at amazon music um
don't
donate it or lent us their uh digital
billboards all around the side of one
building up there to advertise the
ramsey show of course amazon music
carries the podcast of this show
we appreciate them doing that and um so
wherever you listen to podcasts is fine
but a little ramsey show digital action
there going on in times square all the
time square tourists are now tuning into
the show welcome
well i mean it's got my picture on there
so that
probably turned i'm afraid that may mess
the whole thing up but it's got yeah i
think it's rachel and john are there too
yeah i didn't me and ken didn't make it
they'll save it for us but yeah anyway
yeah so yeah you work too hard to be
this broke or something like that it
says so yeah check it out guys if you
run around new york city we appreciate
that and good working with the fine
folks at amazon music we appreciate them
carrying the podcast this podcast is
offered everywhere great podcasts are
offered anywhere you want to tune in
it's everywhere so uh spotify
amazon apple of course um i don't know
wherever else you do that i guess google
play right i heart siriusxm you name it
you got it all there yeah yeah the ram
we have our own little network app that
some people use to tune in youtube of
course
um and i heart we're on the ai that's
right we have our own channel on the
iheart radio app i forgot about that
that's uh that's been there since i mean
so many places you're bound to forget a
few at this point
well i'm yeah i'm lost but um yeah on
top of the 600-something stations well
that's what my that's where i started so
all this other stuff has come along
since then the kids in their newfangled
technology indeed get off my lawn get
off my digital lawn shut up shut up
george open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two we're going to start
this hour off with knoxville sam is
calling hey sam how are you
hey good afternoon i'm doing well how
are you doing better than we deserve sir
what's up
yes sir okay so uh just a rundown i'm
married happily married with three
children
my wife and i
have been married for 14 years something
like that now and um we've got some debt
that we want to get paid off we
we have some some big goals in the
future
and so i just i'm a small business owner
and i really needed advice based upon
that aspect because i think i get
everything else if i have a standard
salary or income like that but with the
idea of being a small business owner i'm
a little bit
uh
i guess i'm ill-equipped or you know
just ignorant of how to handle the
situation but
i'll give you some numbers i've we've
got a truck loan which is my work truck
and it's nineteen thousand dollars
uh we have a mortgage of 180 000 and
then we have 800 and uh just uh two
two different uh zero interest uh credit
cards that are going to be paid off
within the next two months
and um
so i'm looking at a little over 200 000
in debt
and i want to get this knocked out
for my family
so that i can
make sure that we are in a position
where we can help others
uh as well as ourselves and then uh but
what'd you pay taxes on last year in
your business what's your taxable income
um
uh 54.
okay does your wife work outside the
home
she's a full-time household engineer
okay do you i anticipate making more
than 54 on the business this year
yeah i'm looking to
be around 60 to 70. good what do you do
i'm i own a carpentry company we do
finished carpentry how many employees
it's just me and then i sub contract out
to other guys on occasion okay
all right
good for you
okay um
so it sounds like the income is fairly
predictable
uh and you know if you're doing so if
you're doing trim carpentry there's a
lot of construction in knoxville so you
shouldn't have any trouble getting work
for the next while without any trouble i
mean you're not gonna like dry up and
get zero so you're gonna be fine
you should be increasing uh pretty
steadily as a matter of fact so
good news there as far as running the
business goes what we teach folks in
entree leadership is to
hold enough in the business to make sure
the business stays healthy now what do
you actually spend money on in this
business you're a one-man show you do
trim carpentry do you buy the supplies
and then uh
then job ticket the whole thing out or
does do you just supply the labor so i i
do i do some supplies and then i do the
labor and then uh my biggest expense
because i just started last year was
acquiring all of my equipment
which we were able to do predominantly
through a cash flow but some of it was
done through
temporary debts that lasted you know a
couple months at a time before it was
paid off
but it's nothing that doesn't get
knocked down every
every month i i chop away i don't always
have a zero balance there though as i
try and you know
figure out how to do capital and all
that you know do i need to push so what
you need to do is you need to stop that
because that's a that's a rubber crutch
it's going to fall under you
okay right um and
the other thing is you'll end up buying
crap uh in the name of i need another
tool
uh that you really didn't have to have
and and right so what what i want you to
do is i want you to pay cash for or
write a check or debit card for your
equipment purchases and i want you to
hold back a percentage of your profits
before you take money home
now you're you're setting money aside
for taxes every month right
um
yes and yes yes we are
yeah we called it wasn't very convincing
yeah so we we did last year and we
actually ended up not paying taxes last
year because of the amount of income so
we've got money set aside as a part of
our just we just have one savings
account
and how did you not pay income with a 54
000 income
um
so
okay so i think i misunderstood your
question man so after taxes no i was not
at 54. i was down
at 42
i'm sorry not not after taxes after i
was asking what your profit was that you
paid
taxes on if you had a taxable income of
54 000 you did pay taxes
yeah yeah you're right i'm sorry i think
i think i just i think i misspoke sorry
apologies
that's okay so you need to be setting
aside money for your taxes each month
out of your profits before you take
money home and you need to set aside a
small amount for a tool fund
each month before you take money home
and then take everything else home and
then george work the baby steps yeah
this is just going to go in the debt
snowball so let's pay off the credit
cards get rid of the truck loan switch
to a business debit card and start using
cash to run this whole thing and that's
going to keep you from getting into the
cycle where you're trying to keep up
yeah you're you're going to get caught
in a cycle because we work with
construction people and have for 20
years in entre leadership and
i've kind of got that in my dna as well
i grew up in real estate business dad
built homes when i was a kid and so i
love tools i buy tools i don't know what
they do but i need the tool you know and
so that
those of us that are cut out of that
cloth we tend to overspend on
tools that we in air quotes have to have
and i want you to have the minimum tool
purchase because it's overhead to get
the job done
this is the ramsey
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today guys we really value input
from you that watch and listen to the
show
it helps us to know what's important to
you so we can deliver the right content
that will help you with the questions
and the challenges that you have we want
to give you uh motivation inspiration
and information so you change your life
that's our idea
one way you can share your thoughts with
us is by answering a few questions in a
new survey we just launched
you can check out the ram check it out
at ramseysolutions.com
survey takes just a few minutes and we
will do a drawing among the people that
take the survey
someone will win randomly a 500
visa gift card check it out
ramseysolutions.com
survey we
want to hear from you
so it's one of those surveys we found
out how popular george is is that true
it is true i'm hearing it for the first
time yes it's actually came back your
your rate your personal
ratings are very good on the show that's
good to hear
all right that is job security folks so
thank you to all those nice people out
there do they get to rate you too
um
yeah but the difference is i don't care
here we go i care deeply i need all the
validation and affirmation i can get
i've been doing it in 30 years i'm
probably just get off my lawn guys
you're done taking a poll i'm just i
mean i want to be i want to be helpful i
want to be attuned to the customer need
but we're not taking a poll on this is
not like the youtube comment section we
actually want to make the show better so
we want good
critical thinking skills here folks
sorry just busted on the youtube crazy
wow
all right jack is in richmond virginia
hey jack how are you
hey guys i'm doing great how are you
better than i deserve how can i help
all right so today my wife and i just
finished up baby step two this morning
we just made our last our last debt
payment
[Music]
how much did you pay off in the world
uh we paid off 97 000 in 11 months
so we've been we've been hustling um and
the last the last thing you know my
question is
is we have about 70 000 sitting in a
traditional ira
um i'm 29 she's 27. and my question is
as a part of we're finishing up going on
to baby step three here should we
convert that to raw and pay the taxes on
it um as a part of just just finishing
up baby step two no i'm at our age with
that dollar amount no after after baby
step seven you would
okay okay i don't want you to pay tax
bills while you still got a mortgage
okay that makes sense
that makes sense yeah you know i always
hear you guys say the you know match
beats rossi's traditional it does so all
your stuff going forward should follow
that formula but this one i don't want
to convert it because converting it is
going to create a you know a 15 000 or
so tax bill
yes exactly that's what i was worried
about it was another 15 000 that i that
i wasn't looking forward to paying off
uh but i didn't know if it'd be the
smart thing to do or not so it is once
you've got extra money we got priorities
here so we got to get the fully funded
emergency fund begin investing 15
percent get the down payment get the
house paid off and then we have all the
margin in the world because we don't
have payments and you can do stuff like
that
john is in oklahoma city hey john
welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks dave how are you guys better
than we deserve sir what's up
okay awesome well hey i took uh the dave
ramsey advice here sold my duplex and uh
you know take the proceeds from that
and uh i was planning on paying off my
my truck
but uh
i when i bought my house my primary
house in april i had a co-signer because
i didn't have enough uh
job history i just started a couple
months ago and uh i know probably wasn't
the smartest thing but uh
anyways really what i'm getting at here
is uh
i i think i'd rather pay off the house
and i know it's a larger debt than in
the truck just because i'd like to get
this co-signer off without having to
refinance
okay so you got enough cash from the
duplex to pay off your home
yeah yeah but not both
but not both right i put a pretty big
down payment on the house and uh audio
on your house
uh 103 104. something how much you got
in proceeds from the duplex
uh 105.
okay and you have any other money
uh yeah i got my savings i got about 30.
30 30 000 in there yeah okay what are
y'all on your truck
not about 20. okay
um
what do you make a year
uh
this year it's going to be a little bit
lower probably around 45 to 50. uh i'm
just getting ramped up in this whole
thing uh you're single a new
industry uh yep single getting married
next year oh good for you okay
uh i'd pay off both
not much savings but and i want you to
dive in and build your build your
emergency fund up to three to six months
of expenses but i love the idea of
having not a payment in the world that
feels really clean to me
right right yeah i can understand that
i'll have about uh probably around seven
to eight thousand in taxes
um on this on the on the proceeds there
so yeah
but okay yeah i mean i think you can i
still think you can make both of them
what's the truck worth
uh it's worth about 40
38 to 40.
um it's a lot you're gonna be driving a
40 000 truck when you make 45 000 a year
yeah i know i don't know yeah i i
changed my mind i would just sell the
truck
sell it okay
yeah that ain't happening but that is
what you should do
that went over
this immediately and we went from advice
to meddling
[Laughter]
either way you're dead free and now
you're in the market for a new less
expensive truck yeah you really
shouldn't be driving a 40 000 truck when
you make 45 a year because they go down
in value
like a rock that's where chevy gets that
like a rock
and so yeah you don't you don't want to
do that dude that's bad investment bad
place to have that much money parked
when with that level of income a good
rule of thumb folks does not have more
than half your annual income tied up in
things with wheels and motors
things with wheels and motors go down in
value
and so when you got over you make 80 000
you got 60 000 worth of freaking toys
you it's really diff you know you are
you are like saying i am middle class
and plan to stay that way that's what
you're saying right and so uh looking
good in the at the stoplight and that's
it not in the balance sheet
and so um you know wealthy people think
differently about this and that's how
they became wealthy
and uh when you sell for 40 and you owe
20 he can still go get him a 20 000
truck that makes sense
that would be about half of his annual
income and you know and george
i know trucks have gone up but 20 000
truck is not a bad truck no you can get
and people it's not a 40 000 it doesn't
have all the features i want not a bad
truck well i mean you know you know
truck guys you're one of them i yeah i
just drove my raptor in here this
morning tried to park it between those
little
electric things hey you chose that
parking spot dave i well no
i put the little plug in stupid thing
right beside my parking spot which is
kind of like insulting to the raptor it
just that's true it has it gets the
hives every time i pull up next to one
of those little plug-ins i apologize me
and rachel apologize to your raptor next
time we pull up next to it your little
plug-in car owes an apology i'm just
saying truck but hey truck people are
their own breed dave people get onto me
they go well george you don't understand
you're not a truck guy that's right i
need this 65 000 truck well you know
everybody's got a thing where they say
i'm that guy but let me just tell you
what you are you're a broke guy when you
put too much in stuff that goes down in
value you can blame it on the battery
you can blame it on the truck you can
blame it on i um you know
i
any shiny object i had to get i had to
get a new bass boat those with a bigger
engine those bass were out running me i
mean so i mean you can you can figure
out a way to justify anything and call
you i'm a boat guy i'm a uh what i know
you're not you're you catch more bass
with a better boat is that how we're
just broke that's all and so you know
and i've been that guy so you know the
thing is
yeah all of you out there where you just
got it's
drive like no one else so later you can
drive like no one else
i mean i drove a piece of crap
that you know it's made a predominant
color on this car was bondo
and um i mean it wouldn't bring i wasn't
even a 500 car wow i mean
run
and go forward but that was about the
extent of it and i drove that car for 10
years one three month period
um during that three months i saved
everything i could get and i upgraded
considerably to a 1500 car
and uh now what i drive
i got anything i want anything he wants
because i saved my money and i got out
of debt just give me your worst car work
the stuff will tell me your worst least
favorite car ever
i want to know which one of the ones you
own right now oh that i own right now i
don't have a car that i don't like i get
rid of them if i don't like that that's
why they call it a dave car this or
re-branding it that's it this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today joshua's
in seattle hi joshua welcome to the show
hey there how y'all doing better than we
deserve sir what's up
so i am a 30 year old single dad um just
got divorced earlier this year and
i am in about 38 000 worth of debt of my
own
i feel like i'm living paycheck to
paycheck and i
don't know where to start to just get
out of this
i've reached an emotional point where
i'm done i've had enough um
i know i need to set up a budget but i'm
not sure how or anything like that or
what the first step would be
i'm so sorry about your situation josh
how long ago was the divorce when was it
finalized um it was finalized in january
okay
and coming out of this what kind of debt
is that 38 000
um so it is
personal loans i took out a while ago
and credit card debt okay
what's your income
uh 65 000. okay what do you do for work
i'm a plumber
cool
how old are the kids
six and three
your full-time custody
i have 50 custody
okay
well we can definitely help you and
we'll give you some resources as well to
with this process number one getting on
a budget you're right that is the key
and it's a difficult thing to do and
part of this you might need to deal with
the kind of the trauma and the emotional
side to just get you know you got the
wind knocked out of you and so part of
it is just getting back up and going how
am i going to move forward with this new
life and what does this look like
and once we do that then we can focus on
the finances but it feels like you're
just treading water
are you able to cover your bills every
month put food on the table
i'm able to cover my bills every month
i can somewhat put food on the table
i've got friends and
an adopted family around that they help
me out quite a bit with making sure that
i'm fed
and the kids are fed
that's good that's what we want you to
cover first everything else can wait and
if that means talking to the creditors
the credit card companies the lenders
and saying hey here's my situation
here's what i can do right now that's
okay how much do you owe in your car
um i own my car outright okay how much
is your rent
um so i actually have a mortgage and it
all comes out to 2 000 a month
and your take-home pay is what
so my take-home pay is
right around 4 500 a month but then i
also get um disability from the navy
and that comes out to 1500 a month
okay so you're bringing home six
thousand
yeah
right right at it
yeah house payment's awful high bud uh
it's thirty three percent of your time
and um
that's left over from the divorce
happening
that wasn't what you signed up for
that's left over from the divorce but
that's part of what's tanking your
monthly budget so yeah getting on a
written plan will make you feel like
you've gotten a raise getting on the
budget
and uh right so that's going to be very
important but if we take your six
thousand dollars put at the top of the
page
and uh we take food out first and we
take lights and water out the second and
we take house payment out third
your truck is paid for so you just gotta
put gas and insurance on it that's it
and um
you know you've got some money here
you shouldn't be like begging food off
of friends
you're just disorganized you're just
disorganizing have the crap beat out of
you because it's been a hard year
but you've got mathematically you're
okay
you can you can work through this
um obviously you need to cut up the
credit cards and stop the borrowing you
can't co you can't dig it you know you
can't dig your way out of a hole you
gotta
you know you can't just keep get out of
a hole while you're digging out the
bottom you can't just keep digging so no
more debt chop them up get on a written
plan and take care of food first lights
and water second house third then you've
got money left out of that
i mean there's
two three thousand bucks laying there to
do some stuff with and we can begin to
work on this and then the other thing
too is on the days you don't have the
kids i'd pick up extra time
as a plumber you can make some serious
money in overtime or side jobs one of
the two
right
and you know an extra thousand bucks a
month on this debt makes it go away a
lot faster
okay yep that's a short-term fix but
it's a short-term problem if we get
after it
so do you have any cash right now
anything in savings
i got about a hundred dollars
so step one we've got to get a buffer
between you and life and that's gonna be
a starter emergency fund of a thousand
dollars and we're gonna do get that as
quickly as possible we're talking a few
weeks here then we're going to move on
to the debt snowball
which is where we pay off all the debt
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate we're going to walk you
through this in financial peace
university that's going to be our gift
to you
nine videos in there also with that
every dollar that'll help you create
this budget income minus expenses should
equal zero a zero based budget every
dollar should have a job and you're
going to get to work and over the next
18 to 24 months you're going to bust it
to get to a place where these kids see
your sacrifice and you can put food on
the table without having to worry about
anyone else yeah less than one month i
want a thousand dollars less than a
month later i went through these credit
cards gone
and so you're gonna list them smallest
largest you're gonna knock off the
little ones first and get some momentum
like george is talking about hang on
we'll get you signed up also get you
signed up for financial peace university
we'll get you into the class or you're
learning how to handle money and this
all goes in your rear view mirror then
and um
this is the year of life change for you
so uh some of it bad some of it good and
uh we're here to walk with you so hang
on austin i'll pick up joseph is with us
joseph is in salt lake city hi joseph
how are you
i'm doing pretty good how about yourself
better than i deserve how can we help
um so i'm 21 years old i just came back
from the summer of selling pest control
and i and i made a hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars
i i don't have i don't pay for myself to
go to college i don't have any car debts
i don't have any mortgage or anything
like that and i was just wondering what
your best uh advice would be going
forward i i read dave ramsey going
growing up and my parents have been
helping me through it and i've got an
emergency fund set aside for 10 grand
and i mean i could start um going into
investments like roth iras or
i don't know trying to um like save for
a house you know save for a house so i
can just buy it after college what would
you recommend
i i do at this point in my life
so
is this your long-term plan do you want
to stay in pest control do you enjoy it
um i mean i'll probably do it for the
next five years but you said you're
going to college
yeah i'm going to college right now i
currently go every
fall and winter it's 10k total for that
and i pay for myself to go to college
during the summer time i go sell pest
control so i'll probably do that for
five years until i graduate and then
i'll just get some kind of job i'll
probably go into a business management
degree or something like that yeah what
are you studying in college
i'm studying business management
currently okay
did you want to be an entrepreneur and
run your own business
yeah that was always the dream to do but
um
you know just
life beats down sometimes so going to
college right now because i know that's
a very good thing to do at my age and i
can always have that as a fallback but
yeah definitely i would go ahead and
finish that degree as fast as possible
and you've got how much did you have
saved out of this hundred grand
so i have a 117 grand is what i came
back with okay um after taxes it'll
probably be about 88 grand i'm gonna pay
my tithing on that got my emergency fund
and the two semesters and and i bought a
car in cash because you know i needed a
car
good and
young man car stuff what did you buy how
much did you spend on the car
it was nine grand i got a 2007 ford
mustang per pt so i love it very good
all right so yeah
all i'm going to do is what cash is left
after all the different things you
listed out there
i'm just going to stack cash it's
college insurance plan
it's ensuring that you go through
college after that it's ensuring that
you go through college you don't need to
start roth iras you don't need to start
a house fund you need to go through
college
debt-free
and you've you've got this lined up so
you pay your taxes you pay your tithe
you uh pay for the car
you set your emergency fund aside and
then you stack cash and if you graduate
from college with 50 or 60 grand
in that account then we can talk about
starting to invest then or buying a home
then just take it easy man you're you're
just a governor you're so far ahead of
the game you're a go-getter man you're a
hustler it's good us on grind man you're
doing great big piles of cash get
through school then start your investing
in house buying that's what i would do
this is a ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five danny is with us danny
is in boca raton hi ben danny how are
you
i'm doing all right how are you
better than i deserve sir how can we
help
so
i have a three-year-old and a
six-week-old um me and my wife would
like to put some money away for them
we were wondering what the best
thing
would be
okay
are you well we teach folks a thing
called the a process for becoming
wealthy and taking care of all the
different components of our life called
the baby steps
you may have heard of that you may not
but the first thing you would do is not
put money aside for your kid
the first thing you would do is to set
money in an emergency fund of one
thousand dollars a beginner emergency
fund the second things get out of debt
everything but the house how much debt
do you guys have
um
pretty much none we only have two credit
cards but there
there's no debt on them
um
we have about three thousand dollars in
emergency funds
okay no car debt no student loan debt
no
good what's your household income
um together is about
80 85 90. cool well once you've done
baby step 2 which is debt free but the
house all that means is you need to
place some scissors across those credit
cards and cut them up start using debit
cards so you don't accidentally slip
into debt which people do all the time
then we would go on to baby step three
which is finish the emergency fund and
you're short on that you've got a three
thousand dollar now account and it needs
to be three to six months of expenses
once you have that then you would begin
investing in your retirement 15 of your
income going away for retirement and
once you got that started then you start
saving for the kids college which is
what you're calling about
and uh but the best thing you can do to
stabilize
the the family for the kids
is to uh you know to be to be out of
debt and be building your
investments and then in addition to that
we can start saving for kids college if
you click on smart vester at
ramseysolutions.com
you might find
a smart investor pro
that you will find a smartvestor pro
that we recommend sit down with one that
you like that has the heart of a teacher
and you'll want to learn about
529s and esa's and putting money in
mutual funds for your kid's future is
that what we're talking about here
yes sir
okay it says on my screen something
about an iul
yeah we were looking into those because
um
you've got a friend in the insurance
business
yeah
yeah
guess what which by the way he's going
to make other ways
yeah so iul's are awful
it's an indexed universal life you never
do investing inside of an
insurance policy it is the world's worst
place to do investing the only people in
all of the financial world that
recommend that you invest inside of a
life insurance policy are insurance
people nobody else does
nobody else believes that crap it's so
outdated so outmoded it's covered in
fees horrible product
don't do it was i unclear
no sir okay and by the way your kids
don't need life insurance life insurance
is meant to replace your income in case
something happens to you so you your
wife you both need a good term life
policy meaning it's not for your whole
life we're talking about a 15 20 year
level term life policy 10 to 12 times
your income if you have those in place
you can rest easy at night yeah and then
if something happened the two of you
your kids will be taken care of right um
right but the uh and you get that at
xanderinsurance.com they'll shop a
gazillion companies get you the best
deal that's who you deal with so and
it's way more affordable than these iul
policies it'll be uh five percent
five dollars if your iul's 100 bucks
this will be five bucks
it is literally just five percent it's
horrible man so
just stay away from that so you know
walk your way up into investing in real
investments and in the meantime make
sure you've got term life insurance in
place and you've got the whole thing
taken care of
dave i'm seeing this all over social
media i don't know why but the young
people are gravitating towards these
universal life policies and here's how
it's marketed they go you know it you're
supposed to use your life insurance
while you're alive did you know that and
everyone's like oh my gosh this is
brilliant this investing policy inside
of my whole life oh my gosh this is
amazing i'm gonna become a millionaire
and the commissions and fees these guys
are making selling this crap is insane
yeah and the amount of time you have to
spend
pulling that premium every single month
in order to make any amount of money is
absurd well i don't know how it's legal
the indexed universal policy is um
it's a newer version of an old bad idea
is what it amounts to and so what you're
going to find if you take this product
apart and look at the components of it
the insurance portion goes up every year
it's basically what we call an art an
annual renewable term
term insurance all life insurance gets
more expensive every year than your life
period because you're statistically more
likely to die every year your life right
really so if you're 51 you're more
likely to die statistically than if
you're 50. period
okay end of story now why would you get
how do you get then a 15 or a 20-year
level term insurance well it is cheaper
than the average of the 15-year of
increases
the art would start out cheaper and it
would end higher and the lines would
cross right in the middle hypothetically
if it was exactly
how you see what i'm saying so the art
would go it'd go straight up and the 15
year would be level and it would cross
right in the middle at seven and a half
years however it doesn't do that because
it is cheaper for an insurance company
to produce a 15-year policy that because
they keep you for 15 years then it's
called persistence in the insurance
business
than it is for them to try to get you to
stay with a policy that goes up every
year can you imagine that if you get a
bill and every year it goes up you're
probably more likely to cancel that so
that policy doesn't stay on the books so
it's more expensive for them to sell
arts so that result is a 15 year is way
cheaper than the average of 15 years of
art
okay now the index universal goes up
every year inside the policy but you
don't see it
so if you got a 400 premium a certain
portion like on your you know if you
ever look at your mortgage
your mortgage payment a portion goes to
interest a portion goes to principal the
further you go along more goes to
principal less goes to interest this is
exactly the opposite the further you go
along more goes to insurance less goes
because the art is going up every year
inside there less is going to your
investments and so if you keep the
stupid thing long enough it will begin
to be the point that the premium you're
paying will not even cover the insurance
cost
and so it starts to eat back into your
savings just to keep the policy alive
and the thing gets what we call upside
down in the insurance business and so
now you've got a real piece of crap
that's that's eating itself from the
inside out but they pitch it as this
really sophisticated nuance listen it's
so complicated you don't understand just
trust me yeah as your insurance guy i'm
gonna make you lots of money let me give
you a clue okay when you drive past most
cities the skyline has banks
and life insurance companies
these are the two towers in every
skyline
santa claus didn't build those
and those people didn't build them with
wealth they inherited they built them
with money they took from you
banks
screwing you
life insurance companies
screwing you
this has been going on for decades
nothing new it's not a new it's not a
new song not a new dance and just
because you put it on tick-tock for
god's sakes doesn't make it smart as a
matter of fact that kind of dumbs it
down that's a trigger word for you i'm
sorry i shouldn't mention anything i
mean it's just like what we teach is
that you should take the difference if
you pay a five bucks for term life
versus 100 for whole life take the 95
bucks you would have spent and invest
that and you're gonna be way better off
than having touched one of these crappy
policies oh here by the way after you
paid extra on this all these years and
you die they only pay the face value
they'll pay the face value plus your
savings that you've been paying extra to
build so it's like a savings account
with a crummy rate of return
that gets lost when you die they keep
your money
i mean what who would bank with that oh
people that buy stuff on tick tock i
think danny needs better friends yeah
well it's time no i mean that happens to
everybody
because that's how most
particularly whole life permanent life
crappy life insurance is sold is some
old friend from college suddenly
remembers you my buddy from northwestern
mutual said yeah
let's be done with that oh that's
horrible that happened to me that
happened to me i bought it we've all
been when i was a child boy yep i sure
did i did the same stupid stuff and i
have a degree in finance and i fell for
the call now he's a grown man america
he made it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsey show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting for the potts
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
open phones here today at triple eight
eight two five five
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host akosia is on the line in orlando
hey how are you
hi mr ramsey how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thank you for all you do god bless you
you too so
i have a question about my mom her
landlord is planning on increasing the
rent by 400
and she has no way to pay this for the
next year she currently makes about 2
400 a month
so with the new rent plus utilities and
her um personal bills she's looking at
over 3 000 a month
as her daughter i've tried to look for
many different places for her to move to
somewhere um cheaper so she can save
money and
buy a house for next year but she keeps
tossing them aside because she's very
picky anything that's not in her taste
she would just disregard it so
how do i convince my mom that she needs
to find somewhere cheaper so she can
save money she's 54 and she doesn't even
have a single dollar in retirement
savings
she has nothing
but she wants all the bells and whistles
how old are you
i'm 26 years old
okay why does a 54 year old woman
need help picking out her new place
because she
she just needs help with those things
she's not too tech savvy like going on
websites and finding new places you
don't have to be tech savvy to know you
can't live there anymore
yes sir that was a yellow pad and a
number two pencil
she's not finance minded at all i'm the
person who's always on her to pay your
bills on time avoid late fees i always
give her business ideas but she just
tosses them aside she doesn't see the
urgency in um
fixing her finances
uh she'll get urgency if you don't fix
them for her they'll evict her butt
what's her plan currently
just to go into debt 600 bucks a month
she said she she's gonna get a second
job but here's the thing
my mom is a single mother she's always
worked two or three jobs so it's taken a
huge toll on her health over the years
so i really don't want her getting a
second job
and i want her to buy a house and save
money for retirement
but she doesn't understand that she
needs to find somewhere cheaper and save
money
i agree with your conclusion i agree
with your conclusions
and i appreciate you
loving your mom and wanting good things
for her
i am really confused why you're the only
adult in this conversation
with your mom
um this is not your job
she's 54 freaking years old it's time
that she learned how to do something
you know yes so i mean i don't my kids
don't run around taking care of dave
yeah and i don't even run around taking
care of them they're like your age
so i mean these are supposed to be like
adult activities you shouldn't be having
to caretake your mom unless she has some
kind of mental disability and then
you're taking care of her i understand
that but she doesn't have a mental
disability she just doesn't give a crap
yeah it doesn't sound like she has a lot
of drive either what's she doing for
work exactly she's a cna that's all
she's done for many years full time um
she worked three days and then four days
yeah okay so what would i do if i were
in your shoes
now that i'm getting over just being
aggravated at your mother for being
irresponsible okay
um i i appreciate the the journey that
you are on and the question that you're
asking but i the answer is i don't think
you can
do this for her
and i don't think you should do this for
her it's not good for you it's
emotionally weird
it's a boundary violation
and it's not good for her
so instead what i would do is step to
the side
and have a conversation with her this
sounds like this
mom
i love you
and i want you to have a great life
you have worked so hard
for so many years that it makes me cry
that you are struggling
i can't do this for you
i won't do this for you
but i will be your biggest cheerleader
and i'll even coach you on some things i
think you should do
but you're going to have to ask me what
you think what i think you should do i'm
not going to tell you anymore
and if she decides to sit over there and
do nothing and get evicted
that is her grown-up decision it is not
your responsibility you need to wash
your hands of this
it is not in your you can't fix her life
she has to fix her life and even if you
could you shouldn't
it's weird and toxic
so your love for her and your
uh
honor for her for all the wonderful hard
work she's poured in and your wish for
her
that that she has good things is
dependent not on you it's dependent on
her
to go get those things you can't do it
for her
nor can you just
nor do i have a sentence that you can
say to her that says
now all of a sudden this lady who's
never had any ambition get some this
lady who's chosen not to ever deal with
finances at all suddenly wants to go do
that now but what you can do is come
alongside her and just say mom i love
you i'll help you any way i can in terms
of coaching you and i'll be your biggest
cheerleader but i'm not going to do it
for you and i'm not going to carry the
emotional burden of you not being able
to pay your rent when you refuse to
carry the own your own emotional burden
of you not being able to pay your rent
does that sound harsh to you
no it sounds it sounds reasonable i'm
just very concerned about her health
i i don't i don't want to lose my mom
she's 54. she's not going to die from
getting evicted
but she she's had a lot of health scares
because of um
working
so hard over the years she's always had
three jobs because you can't fix it
honey
okay she has to fix it
you're more worried about her than she
is
she's not worried about it
is she yeah
i mean on a scale of one to ten you're a
nine on worrying about her on a scale of
one to ten she's a two on worrying about
her am i right
um you're right yeah so i mean you
cannot you know uh
if my kid doesn't want me to eat pizza
and fried bologna anymore
tuffy's i'm still going to eat it i'm 62
i'm free i get to make these choices and
if my 30 year old doesn't like it
tuffy's
i'm still eating fried bologna and i'm
still gonna eat pizza
and biscuits and stuff okay and dad i'm
worried about your health i understand
but i'm not worried about as much as you
are i'm still gonna eat that
these are choices that grown-ups get to
make all change starts with being angry
about your situation until she hits that
point she's not going to change and
enabling her is not going to help her
long term but you can put your arm
around her and say i'm worried about you
and when you're ready to do this stuff
i'll be your biggest cheerleader
and i'll be your biggest coach
but i can't coach a wet blanket so you
mom when you get ready to move i'll help
you
but i can't do it for you
[Music]
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important
you've got to know where you stand so
you make your next move the right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america this is the ramsey show
tom is with us tom's in salt lake city
how are you tom
i'm doing great how are you better than
i deserve what's up
so uh my wife and i are um at the end of
the baby steps where we're debt-free uh
thankfully in large part to uh to you
and your program and
and uh just some crazy life experiences
that
enabled us to get there we worked real
hard and and that's where we're at now
um
so we are
both now looking into our retirement uh
and but both of us started this whole
journey
in in our 30s and so our
and our retirement investments were
rather kind of pretty delayed we didn't
start investing until you know like i
said our early early 30s
and so what we have now is
uh we started with a very modest income
now my wife works and i own my own
business and we have a
a
much larger income than we had before so
what's your household income now
right now we're close to 400. wow look
at you how old are you again i'm 39. oh
wow amazing you're ancient i can't
believe you're getting around and um i
know yeah and uh and how much you have
in retirement
uh after we so after this year we'll
have about uh about a hundred good for
you good okay and uh how much debt do
you have
we are debt free it's taken us eight
years house and everything everything's
gone everything's gone house and
everything yep way to go dude
way to go what's the house worth
i personally think it's worth probably
about 400 or so but the market says that
it's about 650 so well i mean the market
is it gets to the side you don't get to
decide
so i'm calling it 650 then good for you
man well done well done and you're
making a bank what a great business you
do at this is awesome so now all you got
to do you're what we call baby step
seven so now y'all all you gotta do is
stack up cash now dude and with a four
hundred thousand dollar shovel you ought
to be able to stack it up pretty fast
that's what we're we're really excited
about and we're looking at uh
potentially retiring um in the next 10
years yeah for sure so what's your
question today
sounds like you're doing great my
question today yeah well
my question really is
um as far as the 15
of your income into retirement that
doesn't apply to you you're you're a
baby step seven that's only when you're
on baby step four you can ramp that up
once you get the house paid that's what
i needed to hear yeah baby step seven is
save as much as you can
give as much as you can
live as much as you can your plan
oh that
sounds so great for to hear you say that
if we if we dump in you know 100 150 a
year into this into this uh investment
firm that um that we found through
your smart investor pros um they're
helping us out because i am
very
investment unsavvy so they're they're
guiding us through that yeah um
if we just dump in 150 a year then we're
their forecast says that within 10 years
we could
retire as multi-millionaires and live
off international yeah you probably have
a couple million in that alone and the
house would be worth a couple million
then
so yeah i mean you're going to be 400 4
million net worth at 50 years old is
what it sounds like to me
it's good you see that yeah i mean if
you if you keep making this kind of bank
and you drop 150 in there i mean 150 for
10 years is a million and a half plus
the growth during that time is easily
another half million probably another
million actually
so
10 times 150 is 1.5 million dude okay
39 to 49
so that's what that's exactly what we're
looking at yeah you don't have to have
like a calculator or anything to do that
you can do that one in your head so then
then you just add some you know the
growth that you're going to make on top
of that during that time is astronomical
and so
yeah there's another million easy on
there
in growth in growth yeah uh double every
about seven years or so you're going to
be in great shape just work with your
smart mr pro keep laying out a plan
shovel the cash over there and uh here's
the trick
is to avoid getting arrogant in the
middle of this
and blowing it up before you get there
that's the trick because what happens is
you look over there and you got a
million dollar paid for house and you
got a couple million dollars a million
dollars laying in mutual funds in your
retirement and then you go i can afford
to go do this stupid thing now and
people can you can blow the whole thing
up by derailing just
dance with the girl that brought you
stick with the program
the you know dance with the one that
brought you to the ball just stick with
the program don't get over here and go
oh now now i'm going to bitcoin is now
my aunt put it all in you know people
they get you get a little bit of hubris
and suddenly your brain just fries out
so just don't do that just mutual funds
and paid for real estate just keep it
simple and stack cash and you're going
to be in really good shape man you've
done a great job and largely because a
you're paying attention and b you're
making a lot of money it's a big shovel
that helps yeah
very nice proud of you john's in houston
texas hey john how are you
good guys how are you better than we
deserve what's up
all right here's what i got going on so
um
we have recently sold some farmland that
we had down in florida
um made some cash
we currently own the only thing we owe
on is the house we owe 287 on the house
cash on hand right now including
everything in our checking and
everything else is is 282.
that includes the farmland proceeds
yes sir okay
so
i have
some employee stock purchase
stock
about 45 grand worth perfect
that's an individual stock
i work in houston so it's oil and gas so
it's pretty volatile
what are your thoughts on
selling that 45 grand worth
getting out of the individual stocks
paying off the 287 being completely debt
free
uh house is current valued at about 650
680
um
40 grand or so as the as the emergency
fund and then we can stack some cash
from there
you just saved me some wind that's
exactly what i was going to say i'd cash
it out pay off the house and that
leftover becomes your emergency fund
anything beyond that you guys can do
what you want with go take a vacation
celebrate i mean john you pulled it off
here you got the trifecta you paid off
the house
you got your emergency fund and you
saved george wind all in one answer it
was well done
well done yeah definitely do all that
brother it's an awesome plan you're
right on track what do you make a year
140. yeah and so now you get your baby
step 7 and just like the last caller all
we got to do now is save
more than 15
into retirement load your retirement you
can load your 401k up you load roth iras
up in good mutual funds and uh how old
are you
39
same age yeah
you're going to be a millionaire by the
time you're 45
mathematically
because as the value of the house
increases and you save 25 or 30 000 a
year for the next six years
and the growth on all of those things
you're going to be over a million dollar
net worth by the time you're 45. well
done i'm loving this trip truly a baby
steps millionaire
you know george there may not be another
radio show or podcast in america where
you can call in
and be
succeeding and prospering and find
people happy about it we'll celebrate
with you we are happy that you are
winning we are capitalist pigs
we are glad you are winning no shows are
mad we don't we are we are not angry at
success we think success is amazing we
don't think you're a crook we think
you're awesome we think you left the
cave killed something and drug it home
you're demonstrating work ethic you are
demonstrating character and perseverance
and you are causing these things to
these variables to move you are not
waiting on washington to fix your life
we love people like you people when you
call in here you will get celebrated
here and if it starts pissing off of the
left wing nuts that is just a bonus
you're only fueling dave guys that's
just a bonus
it's just a bonus man i just love it i'm
so a guy making 400k and he's 39 years
old that's just awesome now that's a
trend i can get behind forget bitcoin
that's let me just let me just tell you
let me tell you you know what that means
it means just helping a lot of people
people don't give you money if you're
screwing them you got to provide value
they they give you money when you're
helping them that's how this works
you're providing value you're adding
value to their life in some way so when
you're doing that you are enhancing
humanity well done
well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america have you ever noticed that when
you commit to change in one area of your
life it's easier to make progress in
other areas we met thousands of people
on their journey to building wealth who
accomplished other amazing things along
the way like losing 50 pounds they find
a career that they love they learn to
overcome stress and anxiety
what seems impossible becomes possible
when you have a smart plan
you turn up the focus and intensity on
your goals and that's why we're bringing
the smart conference to dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd it is our only
live event of the fall that is not yet
sold out uh oh i take that back there's
a few tickets left in minneapolis for
the uh building wealth but that's it
other than that this is it and you can
come live in person all day
total
top of the line number one best-selling
authors and thought leaders in each of
the subjects whether it's um
marriage
craig and amy groschel will be there
pastor craig will be there from
lifechurch.tv over in oklahoma city our
friend speaking on marriage dr john
deloney on mental wellness
rachel cruz can
on moneyken coleman on career george
campbell on money there's going to be a
few other surprises i'll be there we're
going to be talking about relationships
career growth everything
it's all day long you will leave smarter
you need new information and new
inspiration to keep moving it is a giant
pep rally there will be about 8 000 of
us there and there are about 2 000
tickets still left so we can still get
you in
the vip and platinum are all sold out
but the general admission is still
available and it's a great great event
dallas texas saturday october 22nd
ramseysolutions.com
events for the smart
conference
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from taylor in indiana i've come into
some inheritance money and wanted some
ways to invest that is best for me at 68
years old i have no outstanding debt and
i'm very healthy i've read much on index
funds but need some guidance thank you
all right so 68 we don't know how much
this inheritance is and we don't know
much about taylor's financial situation
but i would tell her to make sure she
has all of her debt paid off including
the home and beyond that we can invest
some of this money into mutual funds and
potentially index funds um so i think
that is wise uh as far as investing goes
and she needs to be working with a pro
who can guide her because this is
clearly very new to her new territory
yeah yeah take your time and learn about
it um sit down with one of the
smartvestor pros one of the things in
order for
a smartvestor pro to be ramsey trusted
and become a smartvestor pro someone in
the mutual fund in in investment advice
business uh they're not they don't work
for us but in order for us to put our
stamp of approval on them they have to
have the heart of a teacher meaning that
their job is not to sell you something
their job is to teach you
and then you decide to buy it
or not
based on what you learn
but george is right i would have you at
68 become debt free before i did any
major investing and again we don't know
how much inheritance you got how much
debt you've got the other pieces of this
and he's exactly right now an index fund
is typically referring to an s p 500
index fund s p is a company called
standard and poor and they rate the top
500
uh companies on the new york stock
exchange called the big board
okay so they rate the top these are the
largest 500 companies that are that
stock is sold publicly traded on the
stock exchange and an index fund
mimics if you were to buy
each of those stocks
and you bought
500 shares one share of each or five
million shares and it was even
distribution across the top 500
companies so if you take the top 500
companies on the stock market
and a a
measure of all of them as a group
goes up or goes down you are really
measuring the stock market it is a much
much more accurate measure of what the
stock market is doing
than what
the than the dow jones industrial
average there's much fewer companies on
yeah which is just a handful of
companies okay so uh it's kind of the
bellwether because it made back in the
industrial age it made the grade for the
media to pick up on it but the
statistical mathematical measure of the
stock market is really the s p 500 so if
you buy an s p 500 index fund your money
will do exactly what the stock market
does
not any better not any worse
and so that's how we measure against if
you're going to outperform the market
with another mutual fund then that would
be a fund that makes that has a better
historical track record than the s p 500
does and those are actively managed
someone is actually choosing which
companies they think will beat the
srp500 exactly that's a good point so
it's not a mix that's exactly the same
thus it's a mix that is superior to the
the average and they can be weighted
differently exactly you can put it
however you want so and it's all kinds
of different funds out there that do
that but it but an index fund
is um is a very safe play
when you're playing for a long haul
that's not a safe play to do anything in
the stock market when you're doing it
for six months or doing it for one year
which we've seen with the market the
last six months yeah i mean it's down 15
right now and so
you know it's not it's not a safe play
you would have lost you put a hundred
thousand dollars he would have lost 15
grand
you know you didn't lose all your money
i didn't lose all my money but you did
lose 15 000 out of your 100 in the last
since the first of the year and it hurts
to see the balance go down ever when
you're investing yeah yeah so i mean
that's but but that's what the s p is
and what it has done and so what you're
buying is a very boring
mutual fund and there's nothing wrong
with boring we like boring when it comes
to investing yeah exciting is uh is
often stupid so we're not trying to be
exciting here we're not we're not trying
to win any sex appeal contest here we're
just trying to get the tortoise to beat
the hair the tortoise is ugly he's slow
and he's steady that feels like a
personal attack dave but i'll take it
why are you a hair now you call me ugly
slow and steady oh cause you're a torch
yeah i'm the tortoise okay well there
you go
and uh let it be known dave has not won
any sex appeal contests
wow you heard it here first on the
ramsay show wow
sorry it's a family show dave i
apologize this is george this just got
perfect but this is a good point to make
for taylor the goal let's go back to let
me backtrack quickly let me change the
subject to the inheritance my goal is to
be a steward of what was given to me
right this was a gift this is an amazing
blessing and so this is how we see money
through the filter of god has given this
money for us to manage and we want to be
good stewards and not have this money
disappear and so i want to
try to grow this money and maintain it
and allow me to have an incredible
retirement which hopefully she's doing
at 68 we don't know her situation but
that'll be michael if you get a million
let's have that balance remain at a
million and we invest this wisely in
order to do that there you go folks
that's how it works
george campbell here to help us with so
many things you never know yeah he's um
he's he's a helpful lad thank you
if nothing else at least i will be
helpful
but that's what we do here on the show
dave uh i'm i'm just i'm i'm
flabbergasted at you jennifer is in new
york city hi jennifer how are you
i'm doing great how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
all right so i know financing anything
is a big no-no
but correct them under okay
um this in my opinion and my husband's
we're tossing
um we have the opportunity to finance
solar panels versus paying the electric
companies you have the opportunity to go
an adult that's that's amazing i'm glad
you i'm glad they gave you this
opportunity
because not everyone can get this
opportunity
okay so why do you want to do it the
opportunity is our bill will be
significantly lower with the financing
of the pa of the panels versus our
monthly electric bills how much are the
panels
um the payments come out to three
hundred dollars
how much total poor people ask how much
a month
right now with the new roof it comes out
to 97 000. so you're going to spend a
hundred grand to save a few chunks of
change on your electric bill that's
going to take a long time to roi
while you're paying it we figured that
the way we pay off our bills we'll have
it done within five years
and then there's no more electric bill
no anything solar panels are a good
investment if you pay cash for them only
not finance them
and they're a good investment if you can
run a break-even analysis short of about
three years five years is too long to
break even on because here's the problem
you get ready to market the house you
now have a 97 000 extra mortgage on the
house that did not increase the value it
did not increase the value of the house
that's exactly right so you're going to
get yourself stuck do not finance these
things
no no no no no no bad play
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america george
campbell is my co-host today this is the
ramsey show christian is with us he is
in fort worth texas hi christian how are
you
i'm good dude how are you doing better
than we deserve sir how can we help
so i am a currently a police officer
i've been for about seven years now
and uh i've been looking to change uh
careers into the aviation industry
uh get to the airlines but i'm having
some uh
some questions as far as finances go um
you know getting into the aviation
industry is not cheap uh it's kind of a
club that you have to pay your dues to
get into yep and um and so
my question is
i know loans are obviously you're a big
no-no but um i'm kind of looking at is
i'm investing in myself rather than
investing in in
some some other thing that i don't have
control over
so my question would be um should i get
a loan to cover uh flooding my flight
expenses
to get to the airlines quicker or do you
recommend that i save up for maybe a
year or more
uh and take more time and then just cash
flow it
as i go
you're going to regret it if you don't
cashflow it
okay because here's the thing we
discovered
100 of the time
none of our plans execute exactly the
way we think they're going to
right
nothing works out perfect i mean you're
a police officer you see people with
have bad plans all the time
oh yeah
so
you actually have a good plan but none
of our plans work exactly
like we think they're going to i mean
little short plans can you can say i'm
going to get the car i'm going to drive
to work and that plan works out i get to
work you know we don't even think
anything about it no big deal that plan
worked out but when you're talking about
something this expensive this extensive
um the world of
the airline world
the world of being a pilot whether it's
a corporate pilot or whether it's uh
working for a commercial airline is
changing every day
right now right
i mean years ago
you could come out of the air force and
roll into a cockpit
and you know make 200 000
which in today's dollars would be a
million
you know and those days have been long
gone for a long long time uh and now the
airlines have
all kinds of mismanagement not all of
them i mean southwest is well run
but uh the vast majority of them are
poorly operated
every little bump in the gas prices puts
them into a tail spin
no pun intended um they uh i mean it's
just it's a it's a weird world and by
the time you get there it will have
changed it's not it's not gonna be what
you think it is and i don't want you to
have
you know a hundred thousand dollars in
debt
and you're walking up and now you feel
like you've got to take some
horrible pilot's job
just to be a pilot and just to get to
pay y'all pay on these debts and you box
yourself into a corner i would much
rather you have the freedom to do this
at a at the speed of wisdom meaning your
career change and the way you do that is
you don't go in debt for this but um
but the here's the thing i i'm guessing
you've had a lesson or two
yeah so i already have my uh my private
pilot's license yeah and so so you've
already you you've already been
infected yes then that's the thing is
i've i've already yeah i've already it
is it is a disease i mean it's a you you
can't it is so
freaking fun
oh yeah yeah i fell in love with it it
was very exhilarating and
i have never met a pilot that hated
being a pilot
right now some of they hate some of this
crap they have to do sometimes but the
takeoffs landing and flying they
love it a hundred i mean it's very
unusual running and somebody goes you
know i really hate doing this it just
bothers me and everybody it's like it's
like a disease and so you the problem is
when you you got it's it's an addiction
and you got to be careful man you're
going to make bad decisions
in your in your enthusiasm using the
filter of wisdom i just go all right
that's off the table i'm going to do
this how long does it take how do i
speed it up how can i speed it up how
much how much overtime can i take doing
something i don't like so i get to get
my hours so i can move up you know and
go from a single engine to a you know
get a jet license and move on and move
and then get the hours and get the hours
then get the hours and keep moving along
and then that puts you in a position to
choose your gig
you know
like i mean i've got a good friend that
uh is a corporate pilot
and meaning he flies for a guy that has
a big jet and he makes a couple he makes
quarter million a year you know it's not
bad it's good man he's not putting up
with airline crap he's not doing he's
just flying his buddy up there to
montana you know i mean that's all
that's good right and it's a good life
so but but to get to that stage
you've got as he said you've got
christians right he's got some expense
and he's got to get his hours and that
kind of stuff but it's
it's different than
i want to be an architect
and i once drew a plan and it was fun no
no no no this is addicting you just i
gotta get back out there people people
that want to become pilots it's not
unusual for those of you that are in
that category to go do really stupid
stuff in pursuit of your addiction all
in the name of aviation yeah so don't
don't do it just take your time be wise
this is a career it's what we're going
to do for a living and no you don't need
to have a bunch of data you don't have a
dime a dad around it you can do it you
can you can work through the hours and
as you said cash flow it if it delays it
a
little
but that also sets you up for
taking the right job because you're not
some broke guy not desperate you know
what that that's trying to
squeeze your way into aviation
because i mean if you get on some of
these little um
uh the guys and gals flying some some of
the uh regional
prop commercials
um
i really that's when i know i'm old
when the pilot looks like i've got socks
older than them it scares you you know i
mean they're they're just straight out
he just started to grow some chin hair
yes just green man and i'm sure they're
competent pilots so they wouldn't put
them in there i mean i'm not i'm not
just not questioning their skills but uh
for an old turkey like me it's just like
oh my god he looks like he's 12. you
know well they grew up playing video
games so it's not too much of a stretch
at this point
george that was not comforting at all
nick is with us nick is in atlanta hi
nick what's up
hey guys thanks for having me sure how
can we help
uh so my i'm 29 my wife's 27 and as of
last week we became both consumer debt
free yay and
yep very excited about it and also our
emergency fund is fully funded so we're
technically on four five six right now
uh no kids yet
uh we have our house and for us uh we
are planning to move we have a house
here in georgia but we're planning on
selling it in the next eight months or
so and then moving up north pennsylvania
so my question is
do you think it's wise to just pause on
investing right now and instead for the
next eight or so months just try to save
as much money as possible to get ready
for the next home purchase
you want to put a down payment you have
equity in the georgia home don't you
uh i do i do i just i'm thinking that it
might be a little bit better just to
save in the next eight months instead
i wouldn't know i'd say 15 of my income
towards retirement and anything else you
can save
uh above that and you've been paying
more than that anyway on debt so you're
used to living on less
so i just act like it's debt i'm gonna
start but i'm gonna go ahead and get
your emergency fund in place and you
just became consumer debt free so now
you got to do baby step three and four
and no i'm oh you got the equity coming
out of the house in georgia you make the
move with that and just roll that right
into the next house as much as you can
yeah i mean that
i i don't because here's the thing i
don't want to get us
any of us in the habit of jumping in and
out of investing
we just need to be steady
steady and invest steady and invest and
don't don't look for reasons to quit
investing
even if it's temporary because you get
you get used to okay now we're going to
buy bass boats so we need to stop
investing for six months no no no no no
no no well now we're gonna no no no no
no no there's always something
and this is a this is a very it's a
valid question
but what i don't want is i just you know
the the people that we've studied that
became millionaires never stopped
they stayed they stayed with their men
steady and consistent and that that's
that's that that time and consistency
thing is a big deal yeah the only time
we'd want you to pause investing if
there was a true storm a true emergency
and you know this move's happening it's
eight months away it's not it's not
that's the cash you can do this and
you've got you've got money coming out
of the house you're just trying to beef
it up a little maybe move up in house or
something as you're going but i i don't
mind you doing all that but no i
wouldn't stop investing nope wouldn't do
it
hey thanks for the call man that puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the
books our thanks to james andrew zach
ben and austin in the booth the booth
dudes are with us this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsey show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting for the pods
moving in storage studio it's the ramsey
show where that is dumb cash is king and
the paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five mike is in baton rouge louisiana
hey mike welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you thanks for having
me on the show sure what's up
well got a question for you
my wife and i have been following the
baby steps we are consumer debt free
no car loans
other than only thing we owe is um
on our primary residence and then i have
several rental properties
that i've got five that still have a
note on them um i we have two senior
college kids and so we've got about one
semester left and we've been cash
flowing that
so my my question is about the rentals
um
is it you know i've got a couple of them
that have like a one has a note of
twenty thousand one has a note of uh you
know a little less than forty thousand
is it okay to do the uh
debt snowball on those and as i pay
those off
you know keep paying those off and then
move to my primary residence
or does it make more sense to sell a few
of those off and
just wipe out the primary resident
how many rental properties do you own
total
i have ten
okay and five of them have a note and 20
and 40 and what are the kind of notes
uh one is
like 70 another one is like eight a
little over 80.
and then the last one is like 125. okay
and your personal residence is how much
oh don't it
uh
320 and your household income is what
uh my wife and i make about uh a little
over 200 a year cool how old are y'all
55 i'm 55 yeah yeah that's about right
okay
um
yeah uh so
two two approaches since you're since
your notes on your rentals are very
small compared to your house yeah i
would do those first
because they're easy
right right if they were equal i'd pay
off your house first
but they're not equal okay so it doesn't
come up but um um
and so the debt snowball does work so
there's two approaches you could use to
this and anywhere in between those two
approaches is fine one is simply like
you said just that snowball them and
then pay off your house as quick as you
can after that with all the increased
cash flow you got all the cash flow from
10 rentals plus you got the household
income of 200 so you knock out the 300
in what couple of years probably uh
maybe maybe three years something like
that so uh you know by the time you're
60 you need to be done with all this
right that's what i'm saying okay now
if
however you wanted to go crazy and just
be done now
you probably could sell half these
rentals and clear and clear everything
couldn't you
yeah yeah i have about 700 000 in equity
yeah so that's the other side
of the spectrum one spectrum is the slow
way
plot out over five years one's the
instant way now
and you could do anything in between
which is probably what i would do is
something in between because generally
speaking when i meet people that have 10
rental properties they have two of them
they really don't like that much
right
and that's the two i'm gonna sell
and so now now i now i'm not gonna get
rid of all of it right now today but i'm
gonna accelerate this five year to maybe
a three year by picking off two or three
that i'm not that thrilled with anyway i
might not buy them again if i didn't
already own them kind of property
and just clear those notes and those and
throw those equities at the other
rentals and or at the
house and so
none of this is required anywhere in
there is okay
all at once today by selling enough of
it to just clear everything and you know
you've got three cleared properties and
you're cleared house and boom we're done
okay that's today the other way is five
years you slow walk it out and then
somewhere in between a hybrid which is
getting rid of something you probably
don't even like anyway that you don't
you know five years from now you know
that the house is not it's not done that
good it's a pain in the butt it's always
you know it's a older property it's hard
to maintain it's a neighborhood that's
not doing that great the type of renters
i get in there aren't that great
whatever it is something that that's the
way i would find a property i didn't
like in my portfolio i'd be going this
one is less fun than the other ones you
know
what's your long-term plan mike do you
want to retire in a few years have you
talked to your wife about this
well she'd like to retire tomorrow um
but no we're probably looking at
my wife's a travel nurse and and i'm in
sales
so we're probably looking anywhere
between you know probably 10 years from
now
okay this just helps me drive the
decision to go okay if she wants to stop
working tomorrow i might be selling some
of these properties versus using our
future income to try to pay him off more
slowly so i would have a conversation
with your wife about this make that
decision together but i like the plan of
splitting the difference and if it's not
enough we go all right we're going to
sell the next least favorite one to
speed this up yeah and just you know
i'm probably going to pick off two or
three of these that i'm not that excited
about anyway and accelerate this and
make it a three year or three and a half
year plan or whatever but it's a five
year plan if you don't sell anything
it's what the math is telling me just
i'm just doing quick numbers in my head
but i think i'm pretty close on that hey
that's well done sir you've done great
building this up i'm proud of you good
good work a lot of stuff you can do
there a lot of stuff you can do mike is
with us in saint paul hey mike welcome
to the ramsay show
yeah hi dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
yeah so my question is that my wife and
i are looking for some advice on whether
or not
paying off our current home and paying
for a lot of upgrades to modernize it
or selling it and purchasing a more
modern home
um and starting with a fresh mortgage
what's it gonna cost to update the
uh it's gonna house
about a hundred thousand to upgrade the
house we're looking at um signing a
master bath finishing a basement and a
kitchen
wow that's a lot you think that will
increase the value by a hundred
that's that's a tough question um with
today's market kind of changing so much
uh so quickly
um we just know that
you know emotionally and you know it's
hard for us to kind of wrap our heads
around that
um you know hiring out contractors
getting bit having our house torn apart
yeah and then also how long that pro you
know all those projects look like i only
did a minor remodel
that's not as extensive as you're
talking about while i was living in the
house
one time
and i distinctly remember sitting in a
lawn chair on plywood where they had
ripped the carpet up in my master
bedroom watching television and i told
my wife you might be a redneck if
you are in your master bedroom watching
a big screen on plywood in a lawn chair
and so yeah and so i just that that was
the end of me doing this stuff
so if i'm in your shoes i'm just going
to go buy something i wouldn't fool with
it life is too short to remodel house
while you live in it
it's a pain in the butt sawdust in
everything
it's hard
now light remodels are one thing but
what you're talking about is very
extensive it's almost as extensive as
building a house
and
i personally wouldn't do that i'd move
out
and uh i just go buy something life i
mean there's houses everywhere that's
what i would do this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today uh when you're worried
about money it's all you can think about
stress affects your marriage your family
your career it affects everything until
one day you look up and you feel like
everything's on fire
well you shouldn't have to live this way
and by the way you don't have to
when you have a plan you will discover
peace
in your life that you didn't think was
possible financial peace university
you'll learn the same plan that almost
10 million people have
on how to budget how to save and spend
wisely how to get out of debt become
wealthy outrageously generous and the
course includes dr john delony and
george campbell and rachel cruz and me
it's the best version of financial peace
university we've ever done and we're
offering it at the lowest price we ever
have to make it as easy as possible to
get started so decide today
that you're done
letting money stress rule your life
get started with financial peace
university by visiting ramsey solutions
dot com slash fpu ramsey solutions dot
com slash fpu george it's worth noting
that while everything else is going up
with inflation the cost for financial
peace university is the lowest it has
ever been right now i don't know how you
did it worth noting that's amazing worth
noting i have nothing to do with it
someone over in financial peace
university decided lower the price
didn't even ask me it's worth everything
i mean the turnarounds we see in the
first few months of doing this stuff you
save thousands of dollars pay off
thousands of dollars of debt that you
wouldn't have otherwise if you didn't
follow this plan it's crazy absolutely
works all right valerie's in san antonio
hey valerie how are you
hi i'm good how are you mr ramsay better
than i deserve how can we help
um i have a quick question about baby
steps i'm on baby step 2
and after we pay off our credit cards
technically our next debt is my
daughter's braces
um we owe about 3
800 on them now
my question is though should we pay that
all off because my husband is looking
for another job and we wouldn't be
living in the same city or do i still
pay it off and then
move on
you know
okay i'm sorry if you move cities
they're going to take our braces out
no i just didn't know if you pay off
that debt if we have to go to another
orthodontics
if they would honor that or i'm not sure
how that works
so you're in debt for the entire
treatment plan but you're saying the
treatment plan isn't done and you're
moving in the middle of no yes
well my husband is looking for another
job um we're from the north we live in
texas right now and it's just too hot
for us
um so
she will have braces they predict about
two years um
i'm assuming we're going to move in the
meantime but i just don't know
i wasn't sure yeah i'm not sure exactly
how this works so um but it says
you're saying you're going to have to
pay someone to finish the treatment
finish dealing with their braces in
another city right
yes and you're not gonna have to pay the
orthodontist that put them in
well i'm making a monthly payment right
now i know but i mean if you move if you
move you don't have to pay them
i don't i don't know how that works i
don't either i think i think you got to
pay them
yeah well i don't know because they said
it's for the full treatment
so well call them and call them and ask
them and tell them you're thinking about
moving and what what do you owe today
if you were to move
okay and payments
because okay because our next debt is um
our car which is much more so i wasn't
sure yeah you know how that works i want
you know
i'm guessing that there is i i don't
know what they're doing here uh i um i
don't know how it works so yeah you do
want to clear it though
you don't want to have a debt hanging
over your head when you're in another
city on
these braces
okay so you need to find out what the
debt is in the event you move in the
next three months
and uh and clear that and then
if you stay then you'll continue the
plan you'd pay the rest of it off right
if you'd move then you've cleared it and
you're good to go right
yes by the way get all that in writing
so there's no confusion later
don't uh it's not that they would rip
you off necessarily
orthodontists aren't known for being
scam artists or anything like that but
sometimes there's confusion and when
it's written down it gets rid of the
confusion and there may be something in
that contract for the treatment plan
that says this is what you owe us
regardless of what you do with your life
so it may be the case kind of afraid you
owe the whole thing but i don't know how
that works jonathan is in denver hey
jonathan welcome to the ramsey show
hey mr ramsey george uh nice talking to
you guys you too how can we help
um so uh me and my girlfriend have been
dating for around eight months now um i
have
introduced her to your guys's plan
um i'm trying to find the best way to
help her
without being an enabler or any sort of
uh you know back end where she
ends up just relying on me um she does
she doesn't appreciate when i do like
ask her if she would like some money in
the
end when you know there's a couple weeks
where
she would dig down on me because uh she
would uh
she would uh
end up
just saying that she's broke or like she
just can't
find a way out
so i'm just trying to find the best way
to help her without being an enabler
so she's actively asking you for money
regularly
no uh she she never does it's more like
i i to ask her if she would like some
money just because i don't like seeing
her struggle and she's offended by that
um i wouldn't say she's offended she
doesn't take any sort of like offense to
it i need to understand um she's very
understanding she's very caring
okay so what's her problem how much debt
does she have
um i am unsure um she won't disclose
that to me like i said we're still
dating it's not like we're married or
anything like that
but i do see her as a potential
sh i do see as me and her getting
married because uh she's not until you
find out what the flip's going on
yeah
um i mean
she's currently in school
there is times where
she is a cna so she gets put on call at
times um i have you know informed you're
like hey you know can you try looking at
other departments in your hospital to
see if you could get you know any extra
income or anything like that but i just
feel like sometimes um she tried over
here
i'm 24. how old is she
uh she's 24 as well okay
all right um so here's the thing
in your mind this relationship has
progressed further than it has in hers
um
you are you are completely dabbling in
her business and she doesn't want you to
know what it is
correct
you are further along the path than she
is
i do feel like in terms of emotion um it
is mutual
but in terms of finance no it's not
because you're willing to tell her
everything about you and about your
money and she's not willing to tell you
what's going on with her money
correct and that may be coming from
shame and some baggage but we have to
unpack this before this relationship
progresses any further
correct yeah this is a blockade to um
to to you all getting to know each other
better
it at a deep level and called intimacy
okay
and so emotional intimacy and so you
guys getting to know each other and
disclosing and starting to share life
is a precursor
to you guys going to an into an
engagement
and so until she's ready to take that
next step you're standing over here
ready to go step she's not ready to go
um and so i guess you've just got to
find out a is this shame or b is she
just not ready
to move forward as much as you're ready
to move forward there's pos either one's
possible
i i do feel it's more in the shame part
um just because there is points where
you know
uh she is hard on money and she still
tries to refine it with a budget and
make herself make her end you don't have
any idea what's going on
because you don't know how much she has
in debt and you don't know how much
income she has you don't know what's
going on all you saw is your girlfriend
crying that's all you know
yeah i mean i do know what she makes um
she has uh disclosed some information in
terms of like what she makes um what
she's trying to do but in terms of like
um her
trying to hear her debt her student
loans and stuff um i've asked her and
it's more like i feel like she's ashamed
well i mean
you can't go forward in this
relationship until she's can get past
this it's a blockade and so you got to
just back up and give this some more
time or it's a cup it's a cut bait thing
one of the two i don't know which it is
but it doesn't sound like it's that yet
but
at some point we have to be able to open
up about these things in spite of shame
in spite of pride whatever it is
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 825
anthony is with us in colorado springs
hi anthony welcome to the ramsey show
good afternoon guys thank you for taking
our call sure what's up
so my wife and i
are realtors here in colorado and we
paid off
uh our first primary residence which is
now an investment property and now we
just paid off our current primary
residence way to go um we have
what's that sir i said way to go oh
thank you sir appreciate that
um we have no debt um
cars are paid off both of our degrees
are paid off
um my question is is we're considering
an investment our third i guess our
second investment property and the rates
are really high but we did get a heloc
and we did get approved on our primary
residence
and
we
wanted your thoughts on moving forward
with the heloc we did do some numbers
and we're looking at about 500 a month
cash flow
on this particular property
that's when it's rented
correct yes sir
and you know they're not always rented
yes sir and you know renters don't
always pay
yes sir
okay
so
um i'm pointing out the obvious but what
is interesting is that uh those of us
that are real estate people you and me
um one of the things that happens when
we get to be real estate people is they
take our risk meter out and they break
it with a hammer and we no longer
perceive risk and we say things like oh
it's going to cash flow 500
in a perfect freaking world only
you know but nobody says that out loud
that the heat and errors go out and it's
3 500 bucks or roof leak over here water
heater blows out the the pop-off valve
and the half the basement floods and oh
by the way the renter's going to sue you
for that too and nobody brings this
stuff up it's part of the equation
though i don't mind it i it's part of
real estate i own a bunch of real estate
as you probably know
but um yeah the cash flow can be a
a bit overstated when we don't take all
things into consideration so anthony um
i mean i don't know how long you guys
have been listening to us but we tell
folks not to borrow money
okay and so uh the way i built my second
real estate portfolio the way i built
the first one is like you're doing and i
went broke and lost it all the way i
built my second one
is i paid cash for it and it was slower
now you have no house payment dude
and you have a rental property with no
debt on it so it's cash flowing like a
bandit in that sense
i mean every bit of money that thing
makes it really makes it doesn't none of
it has to go to the bank
um and and i'm gonna guess and say that
you said both of you in real estate i'm
gonna guess and say you guys are making
north of 200 grand aren't you what do
you make
uh we made uh
400 000 last year yeah okay i thought
you were killing it
maybe not this year maybe things are
slowing down a little
but but but three to four hundred okay
and um and and what can happen is is
that
you begin to feel bulletproof and you
don't
perceive the risk anymore
in these situations so i i'm always
going to teach you
what we have found to be true with the
vast majority of millionaires we've
studied and that is be the tortoise
slow and steady and ugly
and he always wins the race
and i'm going to save up and pay cash
for it i will tell you that a beautiful
thing happens when you get to three or
four properties
pretty quickly uh your pro your rental
income will buy you another house every
year
that's awesome but it takes a little
while and the first two are like pulling
teeth and you're tempted to go do a
heloc because everything in your real
estate world everything in the world i
grew up in tells you to borrow money
no one in the real estate business runs
around saying be debt-free it just
doesn't happen
but
when i find millionaires and i study
them that own real estate almost all of
them did it without debt or got out of
the debt as quickly as they possibly
could like you did the first time
something drove you to get out of debt
yes sir so you're saying even if we have
to wait till like next summer if we're
going to pay cash that's the route to go
that's less than a year away if we're
not talking 10 years from now yeah you
guys have a great income you could buy
this rental property a year from now do
a little slower with way less risk yeah
just
be steady be steady be steady be steady
here's the thing
we've done detailed research 100 of the
foreclosures occur on the home of the
mortgage
when when a pandemic hits when it when
your tenant goes into
chapter seven and it's uh four months
before the court opens that case up
and you don't get any payments during
that time
you got no issue
or someday it could happen to you like
it did a while to me a while back a
tenant came up and said hey um my wife's
got cancer
and stage four
and we don't know what we're going to do
we're scared and we just said uh well
let's just take it well you keep us
informed we want to stay up with what's
going on but we were able to give them a
break and not have to charge them for a
while
um you know you get yourself in those
kinds of positions that you can be
generous and compassionate when
and you can and you don't get caught by
somebody who's trying to mess you over
in another case where somebody just
doesn't want to pay 30 years and it's
just there's something always messing
with your real estate real estate's a
wonderful investment and i love it and i
want you to do it but i want you to pay
cash that's what i would do if i were in
your shoes it's what i have done
and now i own
several hundred million dollars worth of
real estate
i mean the building we're sitting in
alone is 100 million dollars so um
you know
just as an example but that's you know
it's yeah that's what i want you to do
well you make different decisions when
you can do it with no debt with a lot of
clarity move slowly use wisdom and not
be desperate because you owe the lender
so i like that plan a steady
grace
is the word gracefulness
the the movements are more of a dance
rather than a thrashing about
it's not it's not a mosh pit at a
at a punk rock show yeah and that's
pretty you know
you know basically the the people that
we find that really build wealth they
have this steady move um
you know almost like it's a martial arts
workout or something or a yoga move or
something like that
and uh the tick tock real estate
investors are pretty much a punk rock
mosh pit
and you're going to get about the same
different result i mean there's
different things there's just you're
going to get a bloody nose in the mosh
pit that's all i'm saying there's a flow
to it here you know crowd surfing with
undependable people you know that's all
it is so it's
but yeah that's
that that that's dr john dolone's field
i guess i shouldn't be stepping into his
head dave is definitely he's very
appreciative
but yeah you're yoga
i look like yoga but yeah but the uh uh
that's not the point but there's there's
this
when i find uh
people who have built wealth there's
like i never thought about until just
sitting here talking about thinking
about it out loud right now but there is
a there's a graceful movement
to the cadence they're not rushed to
what you're doing there's no rush
there's a wisdom
it's
can be kind
um it's very strong
uh it can be courageous
you know but those movements have all of
that in play and it affects
how well the investments do
because there's you don't have to force
everything there's not as much friction
there's not as much there's not enough
pressure next
and
uh we take all of that out out when you
put debt on it
and the more debt you put on it the more
wild and crazy and more zero thrashing
about that there is and all that and
it's just um
yeah there is a risk factor when we had
grand step gran graham stefan in the
other day we were talking about that on
his
podcast that we recorded i guess i don't
know has that dropped yet or yeah it's
all out there is it okay iced coffee
hour on his separate channel and you are
on his channel uh once or twice they
were reviewing his portfolio yeah and he
came on here for a little while
yeah a sharp young guy but we were just
talking because he's
you know well-known big-time youtuber on
the uh real estate investing stuff we
disagree on the financial so we well not
not violently i mean we're friends but
um
um
and he's a uh sharp young guy but uh but
it's it was fun it was a fun discussion
but that's the kind of thing i i wish i
thought of that example even when i was
with him that this there's a
gracefulness
a smooth
movement of kindness and a piece of
courage and strength that is different
than when you're leveraged to your
eyeballs you know it just changes
everything this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today colossians 3 13 bear
with each other and forgive one another
if any of you has a grievance against
someone forgive
as the lord forgave you
mark twain said forgiveness is the
fragrance that the violet sheds on the
heel
that has crushed it
true poet look at that he should be a
writer
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
tyler is next in grand rapids michigan
hey tyler what's up in your world
not much what's up in yours struggling
through brother how can we help
um so i would love to run my situation
by and then kind of get your thought
on so a quick summary would be that i'm
graduating from local university here in
december a degree in finance and i'm
graduating debt free thanks almost
entirely in part to my amazing parent
way to go very good
recently in terms of yesterday i
accepted a return offer stemming from my
summer internship
uh one of the largest uh banks in the
country way to go what are in your
opinion
some of the biggest pitfalls or mistakes
that people in my situation tend to make
and what would be the best way to go
about avoiding them
so you're saying my first adult big boy
job out of college i don't want to screw
this up
well
number one the principles that got you
through school debt-free i want you to
carry throughout which is wise planning
diligence live on less than you make
don't go out and buy a bunch of toys and
get in a house and do things when you're
not financially ready just because
that's what you're supposed to do after
college because you're you saw your
friends do it and now they're going dude
you don't have a nice gun why still
driving that beater car you don't have a
house yet dude you have a great job in
finance what are you doing that's what
you're about to be up against in the
adult world that no one tells you is the
amount of pressure and comparisons that
are about to come your way
so if you can battle against that
you are going to be just fine because
you're coming out of this completely
debt free
yes correct what do you drive
uh 2010 ford tourists with about 190 000
miles i love it okay
and what will you be making at the new
gig
uh 70 a year and when does that start
february 27 i graduate december
february
of 27
what'd you say
27th of this upcoming okay oh so this
coming february okay correct yeah so i
have two months after graduation okay
uh what i would do is get a a modest
apartment
furnish it modestly
um
and uh
and
uh
pile up cash and get you a better car
your car sucks
i'm looking at uh looking at upgrading
yeah about about maybe about anything as
quick as you can say five ten thousand
bucks let's move up in car
okay all right uh i if your car was a
better car i'd have you drive it for a
year or two but this one's you need to
upgrade this one
um sure do and but you don't need to go
into debt to do it we're going to pay
cash and so first big cash goal
is build your emergency fund the next
big cash goal
is save up and buy and move up in car
five ten thousand bucks something like
that
um and then you're just going to start
systematically moving towards uh you
know you're investing and start
inventing whatever you're gonna do
you're gonna pay cash for
and we're gonna start saving towards the
first house
um and get your 401 k and that kind of
stuff started probably down in the
summer somewhere
about about a year from now all that
stuff will start hitting but it sounds
like you've studied our stuff like you
know it all i know what we teach i've
been an active listener yeah for the
past two years uh then in high school we
did a curriculum in one of my classes
yeah good it's awesome so the
foundations and personal finance our
high school curriculum set the table for
you that's perfect yeah so you're asking
really
mature wise questions
because you know what does happen tyler
and you've watched your friends do this
maybe is the first thing people do when
they come out of school is um
they go get a car payment
because they deserve a new car
to go with their new job to go with
their new apartment and they usually
rent an apartment or house that is uh
too nice
i did i didn't buy a new car but i did i
mean sharon i got married like two weeks
after i graduated
and we rented a three bedroom
townhouse
and there were two of us it was i mean
you know it didn't make it's dumber than
a rock why do we need three bedrooms but
we thought you know and six months later
we moved into a little one bedroom
because we grew up we got smart you know
and uh had an adult or two speak into my
life and go that's stupid and um it was
and and so but that's
uh uh and it was half the the one
bedroom was half the price i mean it
didn't make any sense to make any sense
at all and he can get some roommates too
i mean he's a single guy coming out of
college yeah
and
but yeah so you're gonna kind of get
stabilized in your
uh
you know
in your uh lifestyle and in everything
and just don't jump in
the problem is people graduate they
start making 70 grand they act like
they're making 700 grand and they go
bananas and it's like they've been
working four years living on you know uh
cafeteria food um sitting on old used
furniture and horrible stuff in the dorm
or whatever and now i get to go out and
have like a real life and then they they
dramatically overspend just blank check
that i think tyler's not gonna do that
no but some of tyler's friends are and
he may already be observing that but the
biggest mistake most people do is they
go get a car payment day one as soon as
they get out of school they go get a car
and a big car payment and it's a very
nice car that they can't afford
so save up pay cash for a better car you
do need to do that but we're going to
pay cash
and then let's just
cash flow no debt any moves you're going
to make past that and furniture whatever
it is you're doing it and he set up the
foundation i mean it's rare to meet a
kid who's graduating completely
debt-free because his parents were wise
so it sets him up differently than a kid
who's coming out of college with a
hundred grand asking us what do i do now
because now we go you got to clean up
this mess for the next three years
exactly exactly so he's doing amazing
he's got three years of your life back
that's the power of following this plan
so way to go tyler and currently if
you're
if you're more normal you've got 10
years of your life back that you don't
have this debt hanging around you this
epic failure of student loans you know
george i was thinking earlier today it's
on on that same subject
the um
our documentary on student loans is
absolutely a must watch right now it's
even more relevant than when we released
it yeah borrowed future uh with all the
discussion of student loans and of
the cost of education and what the cost
of education is going to do as a result
of this forgiveness of the forgiveness
actually comes through
from the biden administration um
yet to figure out if it's
does require an act of congress or not
um this time literally usually you say
that ironically not as a not as a figure
of speech but an actual act of congress
um
does congress have to approve this
spending and most people think you do
and so can he get that through before
the the democrats do not any longer have
a majority after midterms because
they're going to take there's going to
be a bloodbath on that
most people say most people believe so
then what do we do from there and um
so borrowed future
to set you up to have uh the young
people in your life be a tyler
instead of being hundreds of thousand
dollars in debt it's it's just essential
what you study matters where you study
it matters
and uh college choice is really tied
into
this whole epic failure called the
student loan program
and uh we disclose and uh
uncover
reveal
the predatory nature of the whole
program and it's it's the underbelly of
this thing's nasty it is dark stuff it's
nasty and dark and evil
and it's out of control
and it was a well-intentioned idea
that got the federal government's hands
on it which will screw up christmas
and uh man it is a mess
and you know and it still begs the
question that we asked in the
documentary or the statement that we
asked in the documentary that if you're
going to forgive student loans while
you're still making them that is
intellectually dishonest
if they're so bad and so oppressive
and the the
poor people that have been
taken advantage of have that they must
be forgiven
and yet you're still making them
it's just straight up wrong you're
asking politicians to be logical dave
that's where you messed up well critical
thinking skills should be required
somewhere in the vicinity of washington
d.c
but apparently not so well every parent
needs to watch this because it'll spark
some great conversations every parent
everybody that has a teenager every
teacher if you're a teacher we'll still
let your classroom watch it for free so
get in touch with us
it's one of the biggest documentaries on
uh
you know on amazon prime so go out there
and watch it it's a google play it's out
there borrowed future
this
is the ramsey shop
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
you